let me start with congratulations uh i
did not know what really went on to
bring to what really went on behind the
scenes and i felt like i learned a lot
and i thought ron did a great job with
this material it um i have a lot of
questions about the film i like throwing
some curve balls at the beginning to
have a little bit of more
i don't know what the hell i do at the
beginning but here we go so for all for
all three of you if someone has actually
never seen anything you've done before
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why father ted because i
just think it's brilliant have you ever
seen father ted the the television show
irish television show i'm not interested
but but
i meant
not a bit man
what was sorry so what would you you'd
want that
if someone has ever if someone has never
seen any of your work before what is the
first thing they should watch and why
i'd say one film that came to mind and
then i i would say after i'd say it gets
better after that but i won't say what
that film is because that'd be too mean
because too many people that's an
amazing thing
um do you know what uh i no man you
can't can you you just get absolutely
crucible do you know what i'm gonna say
i'm gonna say this film because exactly
i'm i don't think i've ever felt as
proud to be a part of something as i do
with this movie and if people watch
nothing else of mine they'd have a
really thanks man i took the punch and
father ted
um so i thought ron did such a good job
with this and i i felt like he didn't
hollywoodize anything i felt like he
almost shot this like a documentary can
you sort of talk about the aesthetic
that ron chose to tell this story and
why it worked so well in my opinion he's
just all he was always there wasn't he
wasn't he always yes he's always in here
he's always always kind of close to your
face or close to one of the kids or he
was he was moving
seemingly frantically but with great
calm within that kind of dynamic energy
he has all over the set and he was
always looking for angles and he was
always looking to get to the center of
the story and not view it as an outsider
i think he wanted to subjectify
uh the audience to the to the tension as
much as he could as filmmakers often do
but he really wanted and he thought it
was really imperative that he would
you know subjectify the audience to to
all the danger and the threat and the
panic and the pandemonium and all that
which is why he had us do as much of the
diving as he had us do which is why he
covered as much of the stuff underwater
as he did
and um and i think he had a real i mean
look he's become something of course as
a documentary in between
rebuilding paradise the pavarotti and
other things that he's done
um
and so yeah he didn't want to he didn't
want to
he just he was really adamant that that
we could get in and tell the story with
as little emotional kind of ribboning as
possible he thought the film didn't need
that he thought the event was so
extravagant the decency of the people
that were there were so hot was so
hard-boiled it was a hard-boiled decency
it was a practical decency it was love
in action without words without niceties
without any tenderness or gentility he
skewed those moments and he could have
put them in justifiably but he wasn't
interested and he was interested in
people coming together for the one
reason that the thai people and the
british and the americans and the
australians and everyone came together
to save these boys you know so he it
felt very verita in that way yeah also
the the attention to detail with which
he
applied his eye to every single part of
this
um was incredible and just speaking from
like my own experience i remember this
he really wanted us to straight away get
training with the with the stuff we were
doing know our kit because it's this
thing these guys their kit they build it
themselves they modify it themselves
they have this relation they don't even
need to look and they know where their
clips are and that attention to detail
it was so that we didn't have to do any
acting i guess because he just wanted to
like colin said the story is so
beautiful you don't want to emote on
emotion it's such a powerful story you
could just sit and watch the news of it
again but in telling the story what he
wanted to do was be so strict with it
but allow that heartbeat to really just
sort of just sit quietly and allow an
audience to find these people themselves
and i think he did a really amazing job
of it it is amazing he said that because
i read a review yesterday where
someone commented and said that uh
it's just like the rescue it's just like
the documentary
but i think that's where the beauty is
because
it's just like the real thing except
with actors
and it was
dramatic
without the metal drama i love the part
in the beginning where you say
should we go to thailand and boom you're
in thailand yeah don't have to go to the
airport and hug your kids and you know
have a last meal or whatever
it's just beautiful i love learning
about the behind the scenes of the
making of a film uh and in this one i
would imagine you guys all learned stuff
about the rescue that you had no idea
happened what were some of the things
that really surprised you that you
learned that you'd like to maybe share
my my favorite um
part of this rescue um i remember
reading it in the script and not knowing
it i never heard about it in the news
and then i forgot because i wasn't in
the scenes filming and watching it again
in the cinema uh made me just
full-on cry was the farmers who
sacrificed their land um to be flooded
because it's also even they don't even
and again ron just did it so delicately
and there wasn't a big scene around it
it was just
these are the stakes yes we will do it
and the selflessness i could just watch
a movie about them i i just i uh
i get emotionally even thinking about i
think it encapsulates everything about
everything we've learned about the thai
culture about
we will just do this and we don't ask
questions
take it um
i thought it was stunning and it's one
of my favorite moments in the whole film
colin and tom you guys obviously had to
do some serious water work and i'm just
curious um which of the actors
on set was having too much fun and which
of the actors was ready to get out the
second run called cut oh who's how i
know i think this i think no i was gonna
say the safety divers were having too
much fun but maybe they're actually
bored out of their brains
more than anything although they did
seem to be doing pranks on each other
you know when we weren't looking i think
it was an easy day's work for them guys
but jesus the responsibility they had to
keep eyes on us at all times because we
had the tunnels that they built
some of them were like 100 feet long
and they were it was there were 360 i
mean there were total cave systems so
once but they had holes in the side of
the tunnel the holes were about three
foot by about two and a half three feet
and they had various whole panels that
you could pull out so that the safety
divers could swim alongside the cave and
they could watch us at certain moments
and uh
i asked one of the safety divers i said
what's the you know how many films have
you done with waterstones and and he
said oh man i've done so many maybe 20
or so and i said well what out of all
the ones you've done which was the most
which was the most dangerous like which
was the one you felt was the most
and he went
i said i said you're joking he said no
he said look he said it's okay but there
is a moment when we leave you
and we've all talked about when we leave
you at one panel and we meet you
eight feet later at the next panel where
if something goes wrong in that moment
we might be in a spot bother
and i was like [ __ ]
and action colin you're in the water
actors to first position yeah taxi for
farrell
so that was kind of nerve-wracking do
you know who i wasn't i didn't have i
mean i was out of the water so i'll say
me out of the water pretty quick when we
finished that last dive man steve when
it was the last day and we finished that
last dive i was so relieved
so relieved that nothing bad has
happened because it was really safe and
it was very controlled but it was also
the water got dirty over time those
electrical cables there was cameraman
holding his camera there was lights
there was four actors and we were all
kind of and then they had someone as tom
you remind me i forgot that they had
guys with two fans that would blow the
water so they'd come so you'd have to
grab to stop i mean it was it was weird
man and we're all on a crash course none
of us had done this before we started so
yeah it was very extreme it was amazing
experience really to be honest which was
incredible i tell you you loved it vigo
he did you can get that dude out and and
he did it in fairness
like so we'd have like in the set in the
tunnels there'd be you know cables you
know these the the guideline that the
the divers would use and they'd come
loose because we were targeting on them
all day we were doing these stunts and
and they come loose and we had
you know crew to go and say oh you know
that's loosened up we'll go tie it off
viggo just be in there do it he wanted
to do it all he'd be like constantly
under the water i remember once he
turned he said do you want to come with
me i'm going to go and sort that line
out and i said nah i'm going to have a
cup of tea and a biscuit man you know
but he loved it and he was in it
it was actually his fault we did
probably we probably would have done
fifteen percent less diving if vega
hadn't been so adamant that we should
all just be there then you know god
bless him piper piper
oh we all followed his lead thanks vega
on that note i need to stop i'm just
going to say congrats on the movie and i
hope a ton of people watch it thank you
so much for your time nice thanks steve
see you soon
you